They detect when a workspace
is occupied
and report that data
back to us.
I think that feels
a little invasive.
Don't worry.
Data on its own
is just a harmless object,
like a sharp rock.
Yeah,
or a, um, a gun.
[ Imitates gun cocking ]
Pow!
Pow! Pow!
[ Chuckles,
imitates gun cocking ]
[ Imitates gun cocking ]
Boom!
[ Imitating sobbing ]
[ Imitates gunshot ]
I don't like the idea
of the company knowing
every time
I go to the bathroom.
Oh, the two of you
will not have desk sensors.
I withdraw
my objection.
But we do want you to be
the face of this initiative.
This is a chance for you
to step into a management role.
Right now, your co-workers
see you as friends.
Yuck.
This will show them
that you're in charge,
like the boys in blue
or the Man Upstairs.
And if you get any guff...
And you will receive guff.
...just remind everyone
that Hampton DeVille
is pro-data,
and to be anti-desk sensor
is to be...
...anti-data and therefore
anti-Hampton DeVille.
And if anyone
has any questions,
we're happy to have
a friendly convo.
Ooh!
Yes, Tad?
How long can we be away from our
desks without being punished?
Great question, Tad.
No one is being punished.
We're just
collecting data.
But you might want to cut down
on those bathroom breaks,
or you will be punished.
What gives you,
two cis white men,
the right to keep track of
every time I go to the bathroom?
First of all,
I'm not white.
I'm Jewish.
And I have walked
a very difficult road.
Second,
what gives us the right
is we're superiors
and above the law.
But we're also your friends
and the same as all of you.
Do you two
have desk sensors?
Great question, Jessica.
No. But...
We're sorry.
This is like "1984,"
right?
Yeah!
And you guys
are Big Brother.
This is
nothing like "1984."
I'll bet you've never
even read "1984."
Oh,
I've read "1984."
And it was
a fucking page-turner.
I loved it.
The point is we're gonna be
watching you at all times.
So think of us
as God.
But remember,
God loves you so much,
and he's still a cool guy
that you can get a beer with
after work.
Wrong.
God is bad and vengeful
and doesn't exist.
Now, you might want
to get back to your desks
because those sensors
are turning on right about...
now.
[ Sensors beeping ]
Sorry about this,
guys.
It's good, though.
This is a good thing.
♪♪